welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Mission Impossible all movies recap
before dead reckoning part one Mission
Impossible stars super secret agent
Ethan Hunt played by Tom Cruise his boss
Jim gets their next spy assignment your
mission if you choose to accept it uh
someone's trying to steal the knock list
which has all the identities of the
undercover agents around the world this
message will self-destruct so Tom Cruise
goes undercover at a fancy party they've
got these hyper realistic masks and they
find the guy who's stealing the list but
then something goes wrong Jim's like
abort the missions compromised what oh
he's shot no Jim they took out the rest
of the team too and the floppy disk is
gone Ethan escapes though and meets with
his other boss who's like hey don't
worry that disc was a fake this whole
operation was a mole hunt because we
knew one of our agents was the one
trying to steal the disc and since
you're the one that survived we think it
was you Ethan's like no I'm innocent I'm
gonna have to go Rogue to clear my name
so he grabs his explosive gum throws it
on the aquarium boom and bust out of
there his plan is to track down the Arms
Dealer Max that bought the disc he's
like look we were both set up that list
is a fake she's like okay if you steal
me the real list I'll pay you the money
I was gonna pay them all and tell you
who the real mole was then he's found by
dead Jim's hot wife who he thought died
back on the mission he doesn't trust her
at first so they get frisky they decide
to work together and recruit some other
disavowed agents including computer
Master Luther but the noclist is held in
CIA headquarters in this super secure
room where like if anything even touches
the floor all the alarms go off Luther's
like yo man this mission is going to be
very difficult not difficult impossible
so Ethan crosses with events and this is
the famous scene where he comes in on
the wires but this guy up there has got
the hard job a rat comes by and he
sneezes so he drops him oh and he falls
I'll catches him just there famous
cinematic scene long story short they
successfully steal the list but then
dead Jim shows up he's like hey man I
survived uh by the way you didn't bang
my wife did you uh nope nope so they go
on a train to give the list to Max Jim's
in the baggage cart and his wife comes
in like hey isn't it funny how we're
setting up Ethan oh snap it's me Ethan
had figured it out earlier that Jim was
the mole so Jim shows up good job but
now I'm going to shoot you oh let me
just put on my glasses that I'm
broadcasting to the rest of the agency
so they know you're the guy now so Jim
goes to escape on the helicopter but
Ethan climbs up there and he manages to
lock it to the train and they're going
into a tunnel so he's got to fly down
helicopter into the tunnel Ethan jumps
on there takes his explosive gum boom
exploded the good guys recover the list
and the day is saved next up it's
Mission Impossible 2. Tom Cruise has
grown out a beautiful Mane of hair he's
escorting some scientista carrying a
dangerous disease but turns out it's not
Tom Cruise oh it's the bad guy they
steal the disease and bust him out of
there crash the plane the real Ethan
Hunt is just hanging around your mission
if you choose to accept it track down
that disease called Chimera this message
will self-destruct first he's gotta
recruit this super hot Thief lady they
end up slow motion gazing into each
other's eyes and bang but they don't
want her for her Thief skills turns out
she used to date the bad guy so they
send her undercover like they're getting
back together bad guy's best friend
doesn't trust her but bad guys like yo
hoes before bros and he cuts the tip of
his pinky off so he's super in love with
her and she manages to steal the disc
that talks about Chimera so the virus is
being held at the top of the super
secure building Ethan's like yo we gotta
steal it before the bad guy does
Luther's like yo man this mission is
going to be very difficult not just
difficult impossible so he jumps off the
helicopter ropes his way down into the
building he starts destroying the virus
but then the bad guys show up they have
a huge slow motion shootout because the
Matrix had just come out but the bad guy
knows the girl is playing him because
she put the disc back in the wrong
pocket earlier so he sends her out to
get the virus but she injects herself
with it and no one really knows what to
do about this so Ethan jumps out the
building and they capture her they're
gonna sell the virus to the
pharmaceutical company unleash it on the
world control the virus and the Cure
make a lot of money standard but Ethan's
there to stop it he fights with the bad
guy's best bro but he loses the guy
captures him and the bad guy instead of
monologuing just shoots him boom but
what's this Band-Aid on your pinky
finger oh it's a mask he shot his best
friend anything's out of there with the
virus they have another slo-mo cartwheel
shootout then Ethan ends up on a
motorcycle and he and the bad guy have a
hilarious motorcycle joust in a long
story short Ethan wins and proves that
he has incredible hair they give the
cure to the thief girl and she and Ethan
make out at what looks like a kid's
birthday party and they live happily
ever after until Mission Impossible 3
where he's engaged to a completely
different chick he's back to short hair
Crews and his coverage that he works at
the DMV which is sufficiently boring no
one asks any follow-up questions but one
day his best friend shows up like hey
man we need you back in the field your
mission should you choose to accept it
is to rescue this agent of ours that got
captured by an arms dealer Philip
Seymour Hoffman this message will
self-destruct so he busts in there and
rescues her and they have a helicopter
chase but then she's like oh I got a
headache what they implanted a mini bomb
inside her brain so they're going to
defibrillate her to turn it off but oh
they're too late brain explosion ah now
Simon Pegg is the new Tech Guy Benji and
he tracks down that Philip Seymour
Hoffman is going to be at a fancy party
at the Vatican so Ethan uh sneaks in
using his signal signature move and
you've got to have a sexy girl on your
team with a fancy car to sneak in and
spill some wine on him so when he goes
to the bathroom uh Ethan's there he's
wearing the hyper realistic mask
replaces him they go out together sneak
out through the sewers blow up the car
and then capture the bad guy just then
Ethan gets an email from the dead agent
he rescued earlier turns out their boss
Lawrence Fishburne is working with the
bad guy sure enough boom Convoy is
attacked and uh the bad guy is rescued
like 30 seconds later he's already
kidnapped Ethan's wife and he's like yo
I'm gonna kill her unless you steal from
me the mysterious super weapon rabbit's
foot he meets up with his team in Hong
Kong the rabbit foots being held in a
super secure building Ethan's like you
know I think I can make that jump
Luther's like yo Ethan this mission's
going to be very difficult not just
difficult
impossible so he jumps off another
building long story short it goes okay
he gets the rabbit's foot he brings it
to the bad guy but he's like hey give me
the real rabbit's foot or I shoot your
wife it's like what no that was the real
rabbit's foot blam oh he shot his wife
turns out it was his best friend working
with the bad guy not Lawrence Fishburn
turn and also turns out it wasn't really
his wife they were just testing him to
make sure it was the real rabbit's
flight so he busts out of there tracks
down his real wife but just when he gets
there oh terrible headache from a bomb
in my brain Philip Seymour Hoffman beats
him up a bit but then he tackles him
onto the street and oh hit by a truck
whoa he's like yo baby I got a bomb in
my brain you gotta shock me to disarm it
she's like well okay boom Brown and uh
it works she's like you don't really
work for the DMV do you and they live
happily ever after until Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol Ethan Hunt is
in a Russian prison and he has glorious
long hair again Benji helps break him
out and turns out he was in prison
because some serbians killed his wife
and he went on a murder Rampage anyway
your mission should you choose to accept
it this assassin chick stole some
Russian nuclear launch codes and she's
going to sell them to a guy named Cobalt
so you need to break into the Kremlin
and discover Cobalt's identity this
message will self-destruct so he sneaks
into the Kremlin they've got this cool
tent thing that projects the hallway
behind it whoa but the information on
Cobalt is already deleted because
Cobalt's there right now is still in
nuclear briefcase and he talks over the
radio alerting the guards to Tom
Cruise's presence and boom he blows up
the Kremlin Ethan meets up with his new
boss who's got Hawkeye as an assistant
he's like yo since everyone thinks you
blew up the Kremlin the president's
invoked Ghost Protocol the entire IMF
disavowed so Ethan and Hawkeye meet up
with their team and he's like yo we got
no backup we gotta stop nuclear war and
clear our names they know assassin chick
is going to hand over the codes in Dubai
so their plan is to switch the rooms and
use masks to impersonate buyer and
seller the first problem is that Benji
can't hack the server room from here so
Ethan's got a Spider-Man up the walls of
the building bust into the server room
his sticky glove breaks though so he
gets to jump off another building their
second problem is the mask machine
breaks so they have to roll up no masks
and just hope that these two have never
met before the third problem is that
they brought a code expert so instead of
giving them fake codes they have to use
Hawkeye's crazy contact lens to give
them the real codes but at the end she
sees Hawkeye's contact lens so their
cover is blown she in the good Agent
have a girls fight and then assassin
chicks kicked out the window Ethan's
chasing down Cobalt to get the codes
back but there there's a sandstorm
coming so they have a very dangerous
Chase through Dubai and boom crashes the
car somehow Cobalt walks away from it
though and he manages to escape now all
he needs to launch a nuke is access to a
satellite so they go to a fancy party in
India where the girl agent has to seduce
the rich Tech Guy to get the satellite
access codes Hawkeye jumps off the thing
and uses his Magnet Suit to fluke down
through the server room put it in but
they're too late the bad guy is already
hacked in and boom launches a new they
can still abort it if they get the
briefcase so they have a fight in the
car vending machine but bad guy's like
no I want nuclear Devastation so much
I'm willing to sacrifice myself for it
but the missile's really close now so
Ethan has to jump in a car and drive off
the thing crash he hits a board just in
time and the day is saved Luther makes a
cameo at the end where he says yo Ethan
that mission you pulled off was very
difficult this guy's not getting it Izzy
now Mission Impossible Rogue Nation Tom
Cruise has decided to rock the long hair
two movies in a row he's out there doing
super spy stuff one day his mission
should choose to accept it is to track
down the secret crime organization The
Syndicate haha just kidding we're The
Syndicate we already hacked you this guy
with the glasses is the leader and the
message itself destructs with some
sleeping gas they're gonna torture him
for information but this hot British
chick shows that she's on his side so
Tom Cruise shows that at 50 years old
he's still in the best shape of his life
so she helps him Escape she's British
intelligence she's going to stay here to
keep her cover Tom Cruise calls Hawkeye
hey I found the Syndicate but he can't
do anything because Alec Baldwin
director of the CIA has just absorbed
the IMF he doesn't believe this indicate
exists he thinks Tom Cruise is the bad
guy so once again Ethan has to go Rogue
to clear his name he sends Benji some
tickets to the Opera where he thinks
they're going to assassinate the
Austrian Chancellor he finds the
Assassin with the sniper rifle clarinet
he beats him up but there's another
shooter in the sound booth and there's
another shooter down there it's the hot
British gym the only way to save the
chancellor is to shoot him in the arm so
the other two Miss he grabs the British
chick he still trusts her so they get
out of there together but the
Chancellor's car explodes The Syndicate
was really on top of this she's like hey
come find me later for now I'm Gonna
Roll out of here too maintain my cover
so they track her down at her gorgeous
pool house and she's like look there's a
file that has all the information needed
to bring down the Syndicate only problem
stealing it will be impossible oh hey
this chick gets it besides all the
normal security they've got a gate
analysis hallway which you just can't
fake so they have to go down into the
server room and like replace the
security credentials with another no
scuba tanks allowed so Tom Cruise has to
hold his breath for a very long time but
someone turns on the thing so he's
getting all blown around in there
finally he manages to get the right disc
in just in time for Benji to walk
through Ethan almost drowns but the girl
saves him but when Benji comes with a
disc she blasts him and runs off with it
so she's running away Ethan and Benji
are chasing her and a bunch of bad guys
on motorcycles chasing them it ends with
a big card thing off the thing slippy
flip flop so the girl gets away brings
the disc to her boss but he's like hey I
need you to stay undercover more so she
brings it back to The Syndicate but hey
the disc is empty turns out her boss is
also a bad guy and erased the disc
luckily they made a copy but the only
one who can unlock it is the Prime
Minister of England and the girl is sent
to tell Ethan that they've kidnapped
Benji and if he wants him back they've
got to get the disc unlocked and bring
it to him Luther's like yo Ethan this
mission is going to be very difficult
so Alec Baldwin goes to war in the Prime
Minister who reveals that The Syndicate
was a British plan that they scrapped
but this guy went ahead with it anyway
but then Lane took it away from him so
he now he's trying to cover his tracks
so this guy shoots the prime minister
with the trank and oh mask time it's
Ethan Hunt when the real guy comes they
shoot him with truth serum he confesses
to everything so Alec Baldwin knows that
Tom Cruise is a good guy now they get
the prime minister to unlock the disc
which has access codes to billions of
dollars The Syndicate could use Ethan
goes to make the exchange but Benji's
got a bomb strapped to him and he thinks
like yo you want your money I destroyed
the disc and memorized the whole thing
so you need to keep me alive Lane's like
fine and he disarms the bomb and so
Ethan and the girl get to shoot their
way out of there Ethan leads laying on a
chase down into the tunnel but oh what's
this they set a trap for him I'm in a
glass cage of emotion so Ethan's name is
cleared the IMF is reinstated and the
day is saved until Mission Impossible
Fallout so Ethan Hunt captured Solomon
Lane but his organization is still going
they're calling themselves the apostles
they're selling plutonium to a new rogue
agent code named John Lark who wants to
blow up the world so your mission if you
choose to accept it stop that from
happening this message will
self-destruct so Ethan's team goes to
get the plutonium but oh the apostles
are one step ahead and get out of there
and oh nuclear Devastation across the
globe the one guy that captured it's
like yeah since we already won I'll
unlock my phone for you but oh the whole
thing was a fake out so now they know an
arms dealer the White Widow is brokering
the plutonium deal between the apostles
and John Lark and this time Ethan's
superhero Sidekick is not Hawkeye but
Superman yes mustachioed Henry Cavill
they're gonna airdrop into Paris but
don't know it's a thunderstorm and Henry
Cavill gets hit so intense skydiving
scene as Ethan manages to save him just
in time at the French Rave they follow
John Lark into the men's room but turns
out this guy is a Kung Fu Master and
it's in that big bathroom brawl where
this dude somehow beats up both of them
in the end they're saved by Ethan's
English girlfriend agent ilsa Faust
unfortunately she shot him in the face
so they can't make a mask so once again
Ethan is rolling up masculus luckily no
one knows what John Lark looks like so
he meets with the white widow who turns
out is the daughter of Max the Arms
Dealer from Mission Impossible 1 but
turns out out John Lark wasn't buying
the plutonium for money he was doing it
for a service breaking out the apostles
leader Solomon Lane to maintain his
cover and get the plutonium Ethan would
have to kill a bunch of innocent cops so
he's surprised changes the plan knocked
Solomon Lane into the water then dumps
out all of the white widow's guys while
Benji and Luther go grab Lane it's an
epic motorcycle chase through Paris but
in the end Ethan escapes but now Alec
Baldwin's here to shut this Mission down
the CIA thinks that Ethan Hunt is the
real John Lark even though five times in
a row he's proven he's the good guy so
once again Ethan has to go Rogue to
prove his innocence they leave Henry
Cavill here to guard the real Lane but
immediately he's set in Lane free Henry
Cavill is the real John Lark he
explicitly confesses to all his crimes
before he realizes yes it was a mask bad
guys just keep falling for that but he
has a backup plan they're surrounded by
a bunch of his goons it's a big shootout
and as he escapes he stabs Alec Baldwin
now Ethan's running after him and I mean
just a ton of running like Tom Cruise
getting his steps in and at the end he's
living his dream gets to leap off
another building you can finally catch
us up to him but Locke pulls out to
trump card he has Ethan's wife Julia
from Mission Impossible 3. so lock gets
away with the plutonium now the team has
to go stop the bombs but he's not
targeting major cities he's gonna blow
up a glacier contaminating the fresh
water for all of Asia he's hidden the
bombs at a medical camp and it's here
Ethan's reunited with Doctors Without
Borders his wife Julia yeah she wasn't
killed by serbians that was the cover
she and Ethan still loved each other but
they faked her death so she could live a
normal life they find one bomb but you
have to disarm both at the same time and
simultaneously pull the pin on the
Detonator which Henry Cavill has just
flown off with on a helicopter yo Ethan
this mission is straight up impossible
not impossible
pretty difficult so Ethan manages to
LEAP onto another helicopter just as it
lifts off he climbs up there hijacks
this thing then they have an insane
helicopter chase through the mountains
Harry Cavill wow eventually Ethan
manages to Ram him oh helicopter crash
meanwhile ilsa and Benji find Solomon
Lane who has the other bomb they have a
fight then they win they're both ready
to cut the wires but there's no way of
knowing if he even got the Detonator yet
and as the countdown reaches one they
gotta snip and yes Ethan got it just in
time so once again Ethan Hunt has
cleared his name and the world is saved
until Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]